My boyfriend said I ruined dinner last night
because I use whole grain noodles instead of the regular kind.
I just read a fucking post online where the girl was like,
the whole situation turns into a screaming match.
The guy throws the fucking noodles away
because of the way they're arguing.
So she pushes him, and he falls on the ground,
and then he. She falls on the ground.
He trips her, so she falls on the ground,
so he starts pulling her hair.
So she's slapping him to get off of her,
and she's like, am I crazy?
So the guy apologizes to her like crazy,
and they end up sleeping in each other's arms.
And she's like, I don't know what to do.
If you would use any of the fucking, like,
Grace and, like,
you know, cognitive dissonance you use to piece together.
Oh, I think he means he's sorry.
Why can't you use that same fucking logic to piece together, like,
I'm in a dangerous situation and I need to leave?
You don't need to ask 15 of your fucking friends,
is this wrong? If you feel the need to, like,
talk to a friend and ask them their opinion,
it's probably cause, you know,
what's fucking. The deal is,
you're just. You're looking for somebody to give you permission,
and you don't fucking need permission from anybody.
You know, it's fucking wrong,
and so fucking leave. I just.
I mean, I understand saying
because I've stayed, but, like,
now I'm like, are you fucking kidding me?
Look at me. Twisted the wrong way even once.
No, I don't need that shit in my life.
You're an extra thing. I'm at.
You're something. I'm like.
It's like going to the store and purposely buying rotten food.
Like, no,
I know this is super bad for me.
I know I'm not ever gonna be able to use it.
It's not gonna do anything for me,
but this is what I'm gonna spend all my energy on.
Like, come the fuck on.
It's not worth it to be in a relationship just to be in a relationship.
But you're fucking miserable.
You're just adding some shit to your life to make it fucking harder.
Like what? Just to be like, I gotta be him,
huh